[Musique]
l'idée d'une élite mondiale qui domine
secrètement le monde est un grand
classique des théories
conspirationnistes mais parmi cette
constellation de croyances il y en a une
qui est particulièrement tenace certains
historiens y voit même le germe du
complotisme moderne les Illuminati le
grand complot qui explique tous les
autres finalement avec en prime le
symbole du triangle que certains voient
absolument partout que ce soit chez des
vedettes comme Jay-Z Beyoncé ou encore
des politiciens comme Emmanuel Macron
devant la pyramide du Louvre ou
évidemment sur les billets de banque
américaine aux figurent une pyramide
avec un œil au sommet autant de signes
qui prouveraient que les élites
artistiques politiques économiques
tirent les ficelles du Nouvel Ordre
Mondial et comme toujours se pose la
question d'où ça sort au juste d'abord
il y a bel et bien eu une société
secrète baptisée l'ordre des illuminatis
qui a brièvement existé au 18e siècle en
Bavière en Allemagne fondée par un
professeur de droit canonique ce groupe
suscule s'inspirait des idées des
Lumières et ses membres s'opposaient
fermement à l'influence de la religion
sur l'état et ses institutions
paradoxalement les Illuminatis auraient
récupéré le symbole de l’œil
providentiel un symbole chrétien qui
existait depuis des siècles et des
siècles le fait que cette emblème
chrétien qui symbolise l'oeil divin qui
voit tout ce soir retrouver aussi sur la
toute première déclaration des droits de
l'homme en 1789 et sur le grand show des
États-Unis quelques années auparavant a
évidemment donné lieu à toutes sortes
d'amalgames dont seuls les adeptes du
complotisme ont le secret mais le fait
principal est le suivant la société
secrète baptisée l'ordre des illuminatis
n'existait que quelques années à peine
au XVIIIe siècle avant d'être banni par
les autorités bavaroises de l'époque et
qui voyait finalement une menace à
l'ordre établie mais malgré ce
bannissement les théories de la
conspiration basée sur les Illuminatis
ont commencé à se répandre à grande
vitesse autant en Europe qu'aux
États-Unis au départ les Illuminatis
sont associés à tout ce qui ressemble à
des actes subversifs et à la pensée
athéiste puis au cours du XXe siècle les
thèses liées aux Illuminatis se mettent
à alimenter une foule de courant de
pensée étaitroclite et souvent très
controversé antisémitisme
ufologie satanisme anti-communisme mais
deux éléments cimentent ensuite les
Illuminati dans la culture populaire
d'abord une trilogie 100% ironique
publiée dans les années 70 intitulé
illuminatus prise au premier degré par
une légion d'adeptes puis l'arrivée
d'Internet dans les années 90 qui a
donné encore plus d’oxygène et de
visibilité à ses croyances désormais
utilisées à toutes les sauces
[Musique]
plusieurs artisans de la scène hip-hop
et Ruby intègre des symboles apparentés
au complot des illuminatis dans le monde
de la littérature en 2000
amène de l'eau au moulin avec son
thriller ésotérique ange et démon sur
Youtube tout se base autour des
illuminatis part aussi la voix à une
véritable chasse au triangle et autres
signes prétendument liés à ce stratagème
des élites mondiales et puis si en
parallèle certains s'en moquent
[Applaudissements]
qui demeure que toute cette histoire
relève de ce vieux réflexe complotiste
du on ne nous dit pas tout un principe
qui ouvre la porte à une infinité de
croyance toutes plus détachée de la
réalité les unes que les autres